The following content is
provided by MIT OpenCourseWare
under a Creative Commons
license.
Additional information about
our license and MIT
OpenCourseWare in general is
available at ocw.mit.edu.
Good afternoon.
Good afternoon,
everybody.
I am going to start this
morning, or this afternoon,
with a question we had at the
bottom of last lecture's
handout.
But we are not going to
actually answer this question
until the end of today's
lecture.
Let's look at what the question
is, and you can be thinking
about it during today's lecture.
All right.
The question is,
vitamin B12,
which we have already mentioned
once in this course,
it has a large negative redox
potential.
The standard reduction
potential is large and negative.
How does it get reduced in the
body?
Let's think about the problem
here.
As we learned last time,
compounds with large negative
reduction potentials are hard to
reduce.
They are easy to oxidize,
which makes them good reducing
agents, but they are hard to
reduce.
And vitamin B12 has a large
negative value,
so it is hard to reduce.
But, in the body,
it needs to be reduced to be
active for one particular
enzyme.
It needs to be reduced but it
is hard to reduce,
so what does the body do to
compensate?
How does this work?
I am going to answer this at
the end of class,
but let me first tell you in
the beginning of class why this
is an important question.
The proper functioning of a
particular enzyme requires
reduced B12 and also another B
vitamin called folic acid.
And this particular enzyme is
believed to be important in
preventing heart disease and
also important in preventing
birth defects and also important
for maintaining mental health.
This September,
Laura Philips,
who is a recitation instructor,
and I went to Oxford to attend
a meeting on vitamin B12.
And it was a very medical-based
meeting.
And a large number of the talks
were by physicians talking about
treating people with B12
deficiencies that had mental
illnesses.
And they told one story of a
man who was sort of a
middle-aged man who couldn't
really function at work.
He couldn't remember what he
was supposed to be doing,
and so he was having trouble.
He was having trouble driving.
He couldn't remember all the
rules of the road.
And of course,
it seems like in England,
this guy was in England,
that was even more complicated.
And he would leave his house
and couldn't remember where he
lived.
He had all these symptoms that
were sort of Alzheimer's
disease, but he was not an older
man.
And it did not seem like
Alzheimer's was right so
eventually he ended up with this
physician who diagnosed that he
had a B12 deficiency.
And it was great for this
particular individual,
because when they started
giving him vitamin B12 in high
doses, he actually recovered.
He got his driver's license
back.
He got his job back.
And he was able to get back and
forth from home without any
challenges.
I think a lot of the time one
cannot point to B12 as the
source of any mental
forgetfulness.
And people do ask me.
People advertise this.
Like in health food stores you
can buy vitamin B12 and it talks
about improving one's memory and
things like that.
I think that if you had a
vitamin B12 deficiency you
should be taking B12.
But I think if you do not have
a B12 deficiency,
taking excess is not going to
help you do better on exams.
Although, I guess they do have
squirt B12, just a little extra
dose squirted in the nose before
the exam just to be on the safe
side, in case that helps.
I won't vouch for anything like
that with memory and B12,
but nonetheless these enzymes
are important.
And it is important to figure
out how the B12 gets reduced,
so the enzyme can function.
What is the enzyme?
The enzyme's name is methionine
synthase, and it uses these two
B vitamins, vitamin B12 and
folic acid.
It converts an amino acid
called homocysteine to another
one called methionine.
And it also converts one form
of the folic acid to another
form of the folic acid.
And, as I said,
inhibition of this enzyme is
believed to be involved with
heart disease,
it has been linked to birth
defects and also anemia.
And, perhaps,
a real deficiency has been
linked to mental issues.
This is a pretty important
enzyme, but there are only two
enzymes in humans that use
vitamin B12.
Birth defects in one of those
enzymes can lead to this problem
I talked about with buffering
the blood.
And that can lead to death in
infants if it is not corrected,
if it is too severe of a
problem, because the blood
cannot handle the change in pH.
And this one is also quite
important, medically.
At this point,
I think I may have scared you,
that you want to know if you
are getting enough B12 and folic
acid in your diet.
So I thought I would share with
you where you get B12 and folic
acid in your diet.
At the end of class we will
talk about how B12 is reduced.
Where do you get these in your
diet?
Well, for vitamin B12,
does anybody know,
in your diet?
I have heard spinach.
No.
Total, yeah,
cereal that is supplemented
with vitamins,
that is a good way to get it.
But naturally occurring,
it comes in meat,
red meat and other forms of
meat.
This is the one vitamin that
vegetarians say they need to
have supplemented.
And it is not a huge problem
because, as I said,
cereal and other things.
But in the natural diet,
it comes from meat.
And what about folic acid?
Vegetables, yeah.
Folic from foliage,
so green leafy things work.
Also I was at another meeting
with medical doctors,
talking about vitamin B12 and
folic acid.
These were Norwegian
physicians.
They informed me of another
source of folic acid that I was
unaware of, which is,
apparently, Norwegian beer.
I cannot vouch for this,
but that is what they told me.
Also, perhaps a better source
would be leafy green vegetables.
And orange juice is actually
quite good.
Some of you may have seen this
commercial, raise your hand if
you have seen this,
with orange juice,
and it says orange juice,
it is good for your heart?
Have you seen that ad?
That actually is probably true.
And that is true because you
get a lot of folic acid in
orange juice.
Anyway, here are some dietary
suggestions for you.
All right.
But you actually don't have to
worry too much about folic acid
anymore, because now it is
fortified in bread.
In addition to breakfast
cereals, bread now has extra
folic acid.
And this started as a campaign,
because if you are a woman who
is pregnant, you need a lot of
folic acid or the baby can be
born with birth defects.
Now, the problem is that often
you need the folic acid before
you know that you are pregnant.
You need the folic acid from
day one.
And so a lot of scientists have
been campaigning in Washington
for a long time saying we need
to put the folic acid in bread
because the woman need the folic
acid before they know that they
are pregnant.
This argument did not go very
well, and it was years and years
and years of this argument.
And then all of a sudden some
studies came out that really
linked folic acid and heart
disease through the activity of
this B12 dependent enzyme,
and all of a sudden the climate
in Washington changed and they
say, oh, this may prevent heart
disease.
All right.
Let's fortify bread.
That is a good example of sort
of science and politics,
where political decisions that
are made about science are
really based on politics and not
on the science,
but at this point things are
looking better.
Although, some recent studies
have shown there are still
issues for some women in getting
enough folic acid.
All right.
Then we need to know how it is
reduced.
We are going to come back to
this at the end of today and
look at how all the things we
have been learning about
oxidation-reduction apply to not
only the batteries that you buy,
but to the reactions such as
the reaction of methionine
synthase, which is actually
happening in your body right
now.
All right.
Today we are going to talk
about this final lecture of
oxidation and reduction,
and we're going to talk about
adding and subtracting half-cell
reactions.
This is listed as a topic,
but I decided to remove this,
so it is not actually in your
handout, although it is still
listed as being in your handout.
You can cross that out just for
interest of time.
And we are going to talk about
the Nernst equation,
which is one of my favorite
equations, so I am looking
forward to that.
All right.
A couple other announcements
before we get into this
material.
I want to remind people there
is a forum tonight.
We had a great forum last week,
and so I encourage you to sign
up and come to these forums.
Also, the problem set is due
this Friday, as usual.
And then the next problem set
is a really short problem set
that will be due Wednesday.
That problem set just covers
material on Friday's class and
Monday's class,
so it is actually really very
short.
Okay.
Down to some business.
All right.
Adding and subtracting
half-cell reactions.
Suppose you needed to know
something about this particular
equation and the standard
reduction potential for the
reaction of copper two
with one electron
going to copper plus one.
But it wasn't given,
and you are looking in the
table and it is not given.
However, other things related
are given.
Suppose you do find in the
table copper plus two
with two electrons going to
copper zero, copper solid.
And, you find copper solid
going to copper plus one
plus one electron.
That information about
both of those reactions is
provided, so you see the
relationship between these two
equations.
You can use the information
about these to calculate a
standard reduction potential for
this one.
If you add these two reactions
together, you get the reaction
of interest.
You get copper two and
one electron going to copper,
one electron cancels,
and the copper solid cancels,
and you get the reaction of
interest.
If you can add together two
reactions to get the reaction of
interest, what do you do with
the standard reduction
potentials to get the answer for
the reduction potential for this
reaction?
This all comes back to delta G.
Most things are related in some
ways to delta G,
free energy.
The free energy in the standard
state, delta G nought,
for that new reaction that you
are interested in is equal to
the delta G nought for the
reaction that was a reduction in
the added equations minus the
delta G information for the
oxidation reaction.
You notice we are doing a
derivation here?
All right.
Then we know something about
the relationship between delta G
and standard reduction
potentials.
We talked about this last time,
that delta G nought equals
minus N, which is the moles of
electrons, times Faraday's
constant times standard
reduction potential.
If we substitute that into all
of these, we get this equation,
and we can cancel out the
Faraday's constant and solve,
then, for the standard
reduction potential for the new
reaction, which is what we want.
If we get rid of Faraday's
constant it cancels out.
Bring the number of moles of
electrons for the new reaction
down here.
We get this equation,
which tells you about the
number of moles of the reaction
in the standard reduction
potential for the reduction
reaction, number of moles of
electrons, the standard
reduction potential for the
reaction that is in oxidation,
that is added to the reduction
to give you this new reaction.
And that is divided by the
number of moles of electrons
involved in that new reaction
that you are interested in.
Let's use that,
then.
If we go and we look,
these were, are two reactions
that we are adding together.
One is an oxidation.
One is a reduction.
And we can look up what the
standard reduction potentials
are that are related to those
two equations.
The standard reduction
potential, copper two
to copper, copper plus one
to copper.
Again, we are looking up
reduction potentials.
And we can find out what those
are and then we can plug them
in.
Here is our equation again.
For the reduction,
we have two electrons involved
in the reduction and a standard
reduction potential of plus
0.340 volts.
Then we put in the information
about the reaction that was
written as an oxidation.
And so that is minus.
There is one electron involved
in that.
And a reduction potential.
Again, it is entered in as the
reduction potential.
According to the equation,
this is a reduction potential
of 0.522 volts.
And then, in the final
reaction, there is one electron
involved in that.
And so we put the one here and
we can get out an answer of plus
0.158 volts.
And so now we found out a new
standard reduction potential for
this half reaction,
knowing information about other
half reactions.
And so this would be,
then, the copper two,
copper one,
reduction potential.
What about the cells we were
talking about before,
the electrochemical cells with
the balanced equations?
Well, in that case,
for an electrochemical cell,
the number of moles of
electrons released at the anode
is going to be equal to the
moles taken up at the cathode,
which is equal to the overall
moles that get balanced out.
When you balance the equation,
you always want to cancel out
your electrons and have none
left in your balance equation.
Otherwise, it is not balanced.
In that case,
you don't use this.
It simplifies to the equation
that we talked about before,
where the reduction potential
for the cell now,
it is the cell potential,
not another half potential,
is equal to the reduction
potential for the reaction at
the cathode minus the reduction
the anode.
You use this for balanced
cells, and you use this for half
cell reactions.
And so, again,
for a half cell reaction you
must use this.
Otherwise, it is not going to
work out.
You can recognize a half cell
reaction because it still has
electrons in it.
That is a half cell reaction.
Okay.
That is just sort of a little
side thing that will come in
handy in finishing up the
problem set and on the test.
And now we can talk about one
of my more favorite topics,
which is the Nernst equation.
A lot of you have probably
experienced the ramifications of
the Nernst equation without
realizing that is what you have
done.
I assume that pretty much
everybody has had an occasion
where you to use your favorite
gadget and discover that the
battery is no longer
functioning.
A few people say yeah,
maybe that has happened to me.
And so then you start doing
things like this,
where you either get some kind
of recharger or you go out and
stockpile batteries,
which then if you keep them
long enough it seems like they
don't work either.
Anyway, that is all the Nernst
equation in action.
An exhausted battery is a sign
that equilibrium has been
reached.
At equilibrium the cell
generates zero potential across
its electrodes,
so it is not working anymore.
And so to understand this
problem, we need to think about
how the composition of that cell
is changing over time.
This gets back to all the other
things that we have talked about
with chemical equilibrium.
What do we know about this kind
of stuff?
What do we know about
equilibrium and components of
the reaction?
We know that delta G changes as
the composition of the reaction
changes, and we know that it
changes until we reach,
at equilibrium,
delta G equals zero.
We know that delta G at some
given time, at some different
reaction mixture,
is equal to delta G nought,
the delta G at standard
conditions--
--Plus RT, the gas constant
times temperature,
times the natural log of Q.
And Q is what?
Reaction quotient.
The delta G at any particular
time depends on the composition,
depends on the reaction that is
going on, the components of that
reaction.
We have seen this before.
Last time we talked about the
relationship between delta G and
cell potential,
delta E, so we know something
about that relationship.
We know that delta G nought is
equal to the number of moles of
electrons times Faraday's
constant times delta E nought,
the change in cell potential
for the reaction.
And also, this could be applied
if this was delta G to delta E.
It holds if you are under
standard conditions,
delta G nought,
delta E nought,
or under nonstandard
conditions.
If we combine those things,
we get the Nernst equation.
If we take what we already knew
about delta G from before and
now plug in, instead of delta G
nought, minus N Faraday's
constant times delta E nought --
-- And also we are going to
substitute in for delta G minus
N Faraday's constant times delta
E, over here,
and we substitute over here and
we keep this part the same.
And then if we divide by N and
Faraday's constant,
we get the Nernst equation
here.
The delta E at some given
point, for some different
reaction quotient at some
different time in the cell,
is going to be equal to the
standard cell potential under
standard conditions minus RT,
gas constant temperature,
over the number of moles of
electrons times Faraday's
constant times the natural log
of Q, the reaction quotient.
What the cell potential is,
at some given time,
depends on the reaction,
where you are in the reaction.
What the composition of
products to reactants is at that
given time.
This way we can calculate how
close the battery is to being
dead, sort of where we are in
the trajectory of things,
what kind of potential we are
getting at that particular given
time.
Let's do an example of using
the Nernst equation.
Here is a particular reaction.
We have copper plus two
plus zinc solid
plus copper.
And we are told that
the zinc ion's concentration is
0.10 molar and copper plus two
is 0.0010 molar.
And so these are not standard
conditions, so we know we want
to use the Nernst equation.
The first step in doing this is
we will write down the Nernst
equation.
The cell potential at some
given time is equal to the
standard cell potential minus RT
over N times Faraday's constant
times the natural log of Q.
We will have step one being to
find the standard cell
potential, so find delta E
nought.
All right.
To do this we need to look at
both the reactions.
We need to know the standard
reduction potential for both
reactions.
One reaction involves copper
plus two going to
copper solid.
And this reaction involves
two electrons.
The other reaction that is
going in the forward direction
is that zinc solid is
going to zinc plus two
plus two electrons.
We have a reduction and an
oxidation.
This reaction would be
occurring where,
at the cathode or the anode?
At the cathode.
And so that must mean that the
other one is happening at the
anode.
Now we need to know the
standard reduction potential for
the two couples.
We need to know the reduction
potential of copper two plus
to copper solid,
and we need to know the
potential for zinc two plus
to zinc solid.
And we can look those up in a
table.
They are up here,
if you can see them.
I am actually going to write
them down to a couple more
significant figures.
One is 0.340 and the other is
minus 0.7628,
and those are in volts.
Okay.
We have that information.
And now this is a balanced
reaction.
There were no extra electrons
floating around.
This is a cell.
We are trying to find a cell
potential here.
We can calculate that for the
particular cell in question from
the standard reduction potential
for the reaction at the cathode
minus the standard reduction
potential for the reaction at
the anode.
And so that is going to be
equal to 0.34 minus a negative
0.7628.
Which is going to give you
1.103 volts.
This is the reaction we use.
And, again, we are not changing
the sign, because we are looking
up and entering standard
reduction potentials.
But you need to know which is
the reaction at the cathode and
which is the reaction at the
anode to put them in the right
place.
All right.
We have our first thing there.
Now, what do we need to know?
Well, we also need to know Q.
Step two, let's find Q.
What is Q going to be equal to?
What is on top?
Concentration of?
Yeah, zinc two plus
and nothing else,
because it's products over
reactants.
But we don't include solids in
our equation,
so it's just zinc two plus.
And that is going to be,
then, over copper
two plus.
Again, we are not including
solids.
We are not including the zinc
Products over reactants,
and we can plug this in.
We have 0.1 over 0.0010,
and that gives us 1.0x10^2 for
Q.
Step three, we also need to
know N.
How many moles of electrons are
involved in this reaction?
Two.
N equals two.
We have from a copper two plus
to copper solid,
zinc two plus
to zinc solid.
There are two electrons
evolved.
They are not in the equation
because they canceled out.
This one is obvious.
Sometimes they are harder,
and you actually really have to
think about how that equation
was balanced to come up with the
right answer for the number of
moles.
All right.
Now we can plug all that
information into the Nernst
equation.
We are looking for what the
cell potential is at a
particular time,
so that will be equal to the
standard cell potential that we
calculated minus RT.
And R is the gas constant,
so write the gas constant out,
times the temperature.
And the temperature for all the
problems that you are going to
do in this unit is always going
to be at room temperature.
Times the natural log of Q.
And that is going to be over 2
times Faraday's constant.
And I am writing all this out
because we are going to talk
about units in a minute.
Times Faraday's constant.
Now we can cancel out.
We will cancel moles.
And we are going to cancel
Kelvin.
And we are going to be left
with joules per coulomb.
Is that a good thing?
What does joules per coulomb
equal?
A volt, right.
That will do very well,
because we are going to have a
volt here and we are going to
subtract something in volts.
That will leave us with joules,
and a volt equals joules per
Coulomb.
That gives us 1.103 volts
minus, this calculates out to
0.0592 volts.
And, if we worked this out,
this would give us a number
with two significant figures
after the decimal point.
And so that leaves us with
these significant figures here.
We are actually going to lose
one in the subtraction anyway.
And we come up with an answer
of 1.044 volts.
I will mention,
in terms of significant
figures, this is like the
nastiest problem.
Yeah?
Do you have a question?
Sometimes when you look at the
equation, there is a lot of
different things going on,
and you actually have to do
sort of a step backwards to
think what were the half
reactions and what was canceled.
A lot of times it is very
obvious, but some of them are a
little bit longer.
There may be one in the problem
set, I don't remember,
but you will know what I mean
when you see it.
Sometimes it will be just very
obvious like that,
that it will be two.
Other times it is a little bit
harder to see,
and you sort of want to think
backwards to what those half
reactions were and how you would
have balanced them.
All right.
In terms of significant
figures, these problems are
probably some of the worst in
terms of significant figures.
Acid-base is pretty bad,
too.
You notice we started with a
subtraction, and in the
subtraction you often lose
significant figures.
Then we had a division.
Then we had a log.
And then we had multiplication
and division and then another
subtraction.
The only thing I can say for
these problems is that it helps
to really write out every step
and to put a line under where
your significant figure is after
each calculation to make sure
that you aren't getting the
wrong significant figures at the
end.
You cannot, in this case,
go back and say how many
significant figures did I have
in the information that was
given to me?
That is how many I have at the
end.
That is not going to work for
you.
These are a little bit tricky.
A lot of the time you will have
a break because there won't be
many significant figures in this
answer.
And so when you do the
subtraction you kind of
compensate.
Sometimes it doesn't matter how
many you really have here
because you are going to lose
them in that subtraction step
anyway, but just to warn you,
there is a lot of different
significant figure stuff.
This actually would be a great
significant figure problem if
that was all you were testing,
because you have to do every
kind of significant figure
situation in this one problem.
But I am going to make your
life slightly easier.
What I am going to do is do
some of the steps for you.
If we talk about constants for
a minute, we are always going to
be at room temperature in this
unit, because that is just where
we are.
It is going to make it harder
to anything else.
Unless specified,
assume room temperature.
If you do that,
you will find that this is
always going to be the same
number.
You have the gas constant,
the temperature,
and Faraday's constant,
and so there is one number that
that is equal to.
And so you can use this number.
Or, if you prefer to use log
base 10 rather than natural log,
you can take this number and
multiply it by the conversation
factor, and you have sort of
another constant,
which you can use in the
problem.
And, on the test,
I will actually give the
equations in this format to you
on your sheet.
And so you can pick one of
these.
If there is room I will give
both.
Otherwise, I will just give
one.
But it is the same type of
problem.
You just have to pay attention
to which log to use.
And I will make sure that the
number of significant figures
here is not limiting in the
problem, so you don't have to
worry about that.
I highly recommend that if I
provide these to you,
save those extra steps of
multiplying things out.
It will save you some time and
maybe a little bit of
significant figure headache.
Those will be available just to
simplify these problems.
I am sure that you can all
multiply RT over Faraday's
constant, so I am just going to
provide that for you and not
require you to do it on the
test.
What happens at equilibrium
then?
At equilibrium what does Q
equal?
Q equals K at equilibrium,
right.
What about delta G?
What does delta G equal at
equilibrium?
Zero.
Do you see where we are going
with this?
If you have the handout,
you can look ahead.
We know from before that delta
G equals delta G nought plus RT
natural log of Q.
We also know that delta G
nought equals minus RT natural
log of K, because at
equilibrium, delta G is zero,
so we drop that out,
and at equilibrium Q equals K.
We have seen this expression
before, so we know that.
We also know the relationship
between delta G and cell
potential.
We know that delta G nought
equals minus N,
the number of moles of
electrons, --
-- Faraday's constant,
times the standard cell
potential.
Now we can rearrange these and
relate the equilibrium constant
to cell potential.
Combining, we get this,
so we just set those two equal
to each other and we can solve
for K, or at least natural log
of K in terms of cell potential.
And so you can calculate the
equilibrium constant from cell
potentials.
And, of course,
this is important,
because if you want your cell
to be producing some kind of
current, creating energy,
or if you want to apply
something to get a
non-spontaneous reaction to go,
you care about what the
composition of the reaction is,
you care about the equilibrium
constant, and you care about
these relationships.
If you know about K,
you can also think about if the
reaction is really favorable in
one direction or in the other
direction at equilibrium,
do you have a lot more products
or a lot more reactants,
and some of the same questions
we have talked about before.
See how all these units are
kind of fitting together,
and how I told you that
everything that you learned you
have to remember,
because it is going to come
back?
It's back again.
We are back to thinking about
equilibrium constants.
This half semester of the
course is very,
very connected.
You cannot get away from any of
the material,
which is kind of good because
on the exam it is kind of all
related, so doing the next unit
is reviewing the unit that you
already did.
All right.
Let's look at an example of an
oxidation-reduction reaction and
talk about what the equilibrium
constant is, again at room
temperature.
This is going to involve two
half reactions.
We have a reaction with zinc in
the forward direction,
I mean with lead,
lead plus two going
to lead solid.
Lead plus two electrons going
We also have zinc solid
going to zinc plus
two and then two
electrons.
Those are the two half
reactions involved in this cell
reaction.
Now, we are interested in K.
We are interested in the
magnitude of K.
We want to think about if K is
big.
Is K greater than one for this
reaction?
We can do the math and
calculate, knowing something
about the cell potentials,
or we can just think about
whether this reaction would be
favorable before doing the math.
If you think about what is
happening in the forward
reaction, what is happening?
Well, what is happening is that
zinc is reducing lead
plus two.
Lead plus two is
being reduced to lead solid,
and zinc is being
oxidized.
It is acting as a reducing
agent.
And in the backward reaction,
what is happening?
Well, in the backward reaction,
we have lead solid
reducing zinc plus two
to zinc solid.
If we think about,
are there going to be more
products or reactants,
we are really thinking about
which of these two things is a
better reducing agent.
If zinc is a better reducing
agent than lead,
it will favor the forward
direction, and we will have a K
greater than one.
Is it a better reducing agent?
We talked last time about how
to figure this out,
and we talked last time about
the fact that things with
positive numbers up here,
the oxidized species of this is
strongly oxidizing.
And at the bottom with these
negative numbers,
the reduced form is strongly
reducing.
We can look at where things
are.
There are numbers,
there are standard reduction
potentials, and figure out which
one is a better reducing agent.
If we look those up,
we know the zinc couple.
We just talked about that one,
actually, minus 0.7628.
And we can look up the standard
reduction potential of lead,
and it is also negative,
but it is a smaller negative
number, minus 0.1263.
This is a big negative number.
Is it going to be a good
reducing agent?
What do we know about how
difficult it is to add electrons
to this?
Is it hard to add electrons to
this?
Yeah.
It is hard to reduce.
That makes it easier to
oxidize.
Does that make it a good
reducing agent?
Yeah, it does.
Because a reducing agent gets
oxidized itself.
It reduces other things.
This would be a good reducing
agent.
Well, what about this?
Is it as good?
No, it is not as good.
It is probably not bad,
but it is not as good a
reducing agent.
It would be a little bit easier
to reduce than zinc,
a little harder to oxidize,
so it is not as good a reducing
agent, because it is a more
positive number than this one.
This is the bigger negative
number, so this is the better
reducing agent.
If that is the better reducing
agent, then the equilibrium
should lie to the right.
There should be more products
than reactants at equilibrium,
because in the forward
direction, zinc is acting as the
reducing agent.
And it is a better reducing
agent, so it should drive the
equilibrium such that there are
more products than reactants.
And so K should be greater than
one.
And we can actually do the math
and prove that this is true.
This is very much like when we
talked in acids and bases about
equilibrium and K values,
and how if something was a
stronger acid one way then a
stronger acid in the backward
reaction you could predict what
K would be, or you could do the
math.
It is the same principle here.
If we go through the math,
we can plug in the standard
reduction potential for the lead
couple and the standard
reduction potential for the zinc
couple and get an answer for the
cell potential.
What is N for this?
This is also a fairly simple
one?
Two.
We know N is two.
And then we can plug into our
equation.
That is all we really needed to
know to do this one.
We needed to know the standard
potential for the reaction,
which we calculated,
Faraday's constant,
we need to know N and RT.
And so we can put those in.
And I will also provide this
with the math worked out for
Faraday's constant and R and T.
And so we can plug that in and
put in our two and put in the
number of volts,
the standard cell potential
that we calculated just before,
and go back and calculate for
K.
And so K is 21.5.
That is definitely bigger than
one.
That is a very big number.
Sorry, log of K,
and K turns out to be a very,
very big number.
And so the forward reaction is
definitely favored,
which is what we assumed
thinking about which was a
better reducing agent.
It said that the forward
reaction should be favored,
that K should be greater than
one.
And when you do the math you
find that K is,
in fact, greater than one.
It is favored in that
direction.
More products than reactants at
equilibrium.
In the last couple of minutes,
then, I want to go back to
biological systems and show you
that the same equations apply.
All the same principles apply
that you just learned to a
biological system.
Answering the question of how
B12 is reduced in the body --
-- B12 is reduced in the body
by a protein called flavodoxin,
and this contains another B
vitamin, a flavin B vitamin.
If we look at the standard cell
potentials, the reduction
potentials for these reactions,
the reduction potential E
nought for vitamin B12 is minus
0.526 volts.
That is a very low number for a
biological system.
That is one of the lowest
standard reduction potentials
that is known.
Flavodoxin is minus 0.23 volts.
Let's think about this reaction
and whether it is favorable or
not.
B12, then, is a better reducing
agent than flavodoxin.
It has a more negative number.
As we just saw in the last
example, that makes it a better
reducing agent.
It is hard to reduce B12,
easier to oxidize.
Flavodoxin has a more positive
number.
Just like we saw in the last
one, it is not as good a
reducing agent.
If this reaction occurred
spontaneously,
B12 should be reducing
flavodoxin, not the other way
around.
We just worked an example where
we saw there was one thing that
was a really good reducing agent
and another wasn't as good.
And we had an enormous K,
so it was very much favored in
the other direction.
This should not be occurring.
It doesn't seem possible that
this is occurring,
yet it is.
Is the reduction spontaneous?
No, it wouldn't be.
Let's actually calculate the
numbers and see how bad it is.
Again, you can use this exact
same equation.
Instead of calling things
cathodes and anodes,
you can just consider it in
terms of the reduction and the
oxidation.
And we can plug in the values.
What is being reduced is B12.
What is being oxidized is
flavodoxin in the body.
We can put in the numbers,
minus 0.526 volts.
And then it is minus a negative
number of minus 0.23 volts.
And we get out that the cell
potential is minus 0.296 volts.
That is not going to be
spontaneous.
It is a negative number for
delta E of the cell,
which is going to mean what
about delta G?
It is going to be positive.
No, it is definitely not
spontaneous.
And then we can continue to go
on and plug in these numbers and
calculate what delta G nought
would be.
By this equation,
that we have seen many times
today, it is a one electron
reduction, so one electron is
involved.
We plug in Faraday's constant
and we plug in the cell
potential, and we get plus 28.6
kilojoules per mole.
That is a very positive number.
It is a pretty big number for
delta G.
So how does this reaction go?
Why don't we all have heart
disease, megaloblastic anemia,
problems finding our way home?
What happens?
Well, the answer is that the
body has to apply energy to get
the reaction to go.
In this case,
the energy comes in the form of
a molecule called
s-adenosylmethionine.
And the cleavage of
s-adenosylmethionine generates,
the delta G for that is,
minus 37.6 kilojoules per mole,
so it is very favorable.
And it is more favorable than
this reaction is unfavorable.
When you put those things
together, it goes.
What do you call it when you
have a cell in which an
unfavorable reaction is driven
by applying energy?
What was that called that we
talked about last time?
Yeah, electrolytic cell.
The body just does the same
thing that you would to drive
any non-spontaneous reaction.
It comes up with an energy
source, couples the reaction,
and then the reaction goes.
Again, same principles that
apply.